welcome everyone to part three in our
series on grounded language
understanding recall that in part two we
focused on speakers speakers in our
sense take non-linguistic
representations as inputs and generate
language on that basis
listeners are kind of the converse of
that they accept linguistic inputs and
try to make a guess about the state of
the world on the basis of that
linguistic input
for this unit for in terms of modeling
our focus is going to be on speakers but
i think it's helpful to have the
listener perspective in mind as you
create speakers and you might even bring
in the listener perspective as part of
your original system and i'll cover some
techniques for doing that in the context
of the rational speech x model a bit
later in this series
now to make the speaker test meaningful
we need to complicate our previous task
a little bit so in part two we had for
the speaker just a single color as input
and their task was to produce a
description on that basis
for listeners we're going to move to a
more complicated task and this is the
task that's our focus for the entire
unit it comes from the stanford colors
and context corpus and for that corpus a
context is not just a single color
representation but now three colors
and the idea is that the speaker is
privately told which of those three is
their target and they produce a
description that will hopefully
communicate to a listener who's looking
at those same three colors which one was
the speaker's target
you can see that that gets really
interesting and grounded very quickly so
in this first case the three colors are
very different and the speaker simply
said blue and that seems to get the job
done and i think a listener receiving
blue as input would know which of these
three colors was the speaker's private
target
when we moved to the second context
though we have two competing blues
they're very similar and as a result the
speaker said the darker blue one and the
idea is that this comparative here
darker blue is making implicit reference
not only to the target but to the at
least one of the two distractors
third example is similar teal not the
two that are more green that's really
grounded in the full context here the
speaker is not only identifying
properties of the target but also
properties of the distractor in order to
draw out contrasts
and i think the final two examples here
are interesting uh in in different ways
so here we have
the target on the left in the first
example the speaker said purple and in
the second example the speaker said blue
even though these are identical colors
here for the targets the reason we saw
variation is because the distractors are
so different and that just shows you
that even though this is a simple task
it is meaningfully grounded in the full
context that we're talking about
now what we'll do for our listeners is
to essentially give them these
utterances as inputs and have them
function as classifiers making a guess
about which of the three colors is the
most likely give that the speaker was
trying to refer to
so in a little more detail here's the
neural listener model it's again an
encoder decoder architecture for the
encoder side we can imagine some
recurrent neural network or something
that is going to consume a sequence of
tokens
look them up in an embedding space and
then have some sequence of hidden states
for the decoder the handoff happens for
the final encoder state presumably and
what we're going to do here is extract
some statistics in this case a mean and
a covariance matrix and use those for
scoring so in a little more detail
we have those three colors as given for
the listener those are represented down
here we'll embed those in some color
space we can use the fourier transform
just like we did for the speakers at the
end of the previous screencast
and then we'll use those extracted
statistics from the encoder to create a
scoring function
and then we just need to divide a
softmax classifier on top of those
scores and it will be that module
that makes a guess based on this encoder
representation about which of the three
colors the speaker was referring to so
fundamentally a kind of classification
decision in this continuous space of
colors and encoder representations
now once we start thinking in this mode
i think a lot of other tasks can be
thought of as listener-based
communication tests so even the simplest
classifiers are listeners in our sense
they consume language and they make an
inference about the world usually in a
very structured space right so even like
in the simple case of our sentiment
analysis you receive a linguistic input
and you make a guess about whether the
state is positive negative or neutral
uh that's a common classifier but
thinking of it as a communication task
might bring new dimensions to the
problem
semantic parsers are also complex
listeners they consume language they
create a rich latent representations
kind of logical form and then they
predict into some structured prediction
space like a database or something like
that
scene generation is clearly a kind of
listener task in this task you map from
language to structured representations
of visual scenes
so it's a very complicated version of
our simple simple color reference
problem
young had all explored the idea that we
might learn visual denotations for
linguistic expressions mapping from
language into some highly structured
space similar to scene description
may it all 2015 develop a sequence to
sequence model that's very much like the
above but the idea is that instead of
having
simple uh output spaces we have entire
navigational instructions that we want
to give so that's going from a
linguistic input into some kind of
action sequence
and finally the serial bar data set is
an interesting one to explore in our
context
that was a task of learning to execute
execute full instructions so that's
again mapping from pretty complicated
utterances into some embedded action
that you want to take in a game world
and that could be a very exciting
extension of what we've just been
covering